Let's go
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my black
widow movie review video we finally have marvel
movies that you can go see this year black widow
is also coming to disney plus july 9th so you can
watch it whichever way you want in a theater or
on disney plus once the movie fully comes out and
people have a chance to see it i will be doing
full easter egg videos breakdowns talking about
the multiple post credit scenes so when you do
see the movie do make sure that you stay after
the credits but if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all those videos we'll
do a new giveaway for disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite black widow moment from the
earlier marvel movies on the video phase 1 phase 2
phase 3 black widow and just a heads up if you're
not sure what's going on with all the disney plus
stuff but black widow is going to be the only
marvel movie that they premiered on disney plus
all the other marvel phase 4 movies are going
to be released the normal way in theaters
but because i'm posting this about 10 days or so
before the movie comes out most places i'm going
to keep it as non-spoilery as possible especially
early in the video here but the black widow movie
is basically marvel's attempt at doing a boring
film it was trying to be born identity which is
still my favorite bourne movie but black would
have never quite got to that level florence pugh
was amazing as yelena belova and scarlett
johansson was as good as she's ever been
so if you're a big black widow stan before
this you are really going to enjoy this movie
i will get into some of the things that i thought
they did not do so well there were a couple
characters that i felt like were dramatically
under-serviced and i hope they fixed that in
future projects but i'll talk about that later in
the video the movie itself is meant to take place
between the events of captain america civil war
and before the events of avengers infinity war
which is why her hair is the classic red in the
movie and she is alive for the most part the movie
addresses her going back to wrap up her backstory
things that she left unfinished when she defected
to the united states and started working for nick
fury shield and hawkeye basically give you all the
backstory that they only hinted at in the other
marvel movies there were plans to make a black
mood a movie a long time ago kevin feige did
try to make one when he originally should have
made one back during marvel phase two it is like
the finest marvel phase two movie brought to you
during marvel phase four so you will feel a lot
of that energy going into the film like wow it
took this long for them to explain her backstory
but they do answer most of the biggest questions
you've had about her since iron man 2. and they
did develop this movie when they were working on
avengers infinity war and avengers end game so for
better or worse there were a lot of things that
they didn't do for black widow during infinity war
and end game that people complained about but they
did things that way on purpose knowing that they'd
be covering it during the black widow film the
same thing happened with scarlet witch and visions
characters during infinity war in avengers endgame
they knew they were going to make the wanddavision
series so there was a lot of stuff for her
character and for vision that they just decided
to cut out of those movies and just basically
copy and paste the story lines into wandavision
episodes and it's not marvel's first attempt at
doing a prequel set movie in the timeline like
they did captain america the first avenger so
they did jump backwards in the timeline before
this and kevin feige did say that they'd be open
to doing that again like doing movies set in the
past even though for the most part you expect new
marvel movies to push the timeline forward there
are parts of this film that do that i can't really
talk too much about that without getting into
spoilers can i wait for the prequel movie about
the rat from avengers end game the most important
rat in the history of the universe but as a person
who spends a lot of time watching marvel movies
marvel disney plus series making videos about
them just analyzing everything way too much i was
happy with the way the movie answered a lot of
the biggest questions about her character and the
funny thing is too as much as they're selling this
as a big action thrill ride like a big born action
film there's actually way more character work
and just smaller moments of them just talking to
each other just having these family moments that
they've been selling in all the trailers than you
would expect in fact there were actually far fewer
action scenes than i would expect so it doesn't
move quite as quickly as a traditional bourne
film there are a couple parts of the film that
drag just a little bit because they do so much
character work early on before they hit the third
act so it does kind of hurt things at the end of
the film because they sort of rush a lot of what
happens at the end usually things like that can be
solved by just doing it as say like a disney plus
series so you get an extra couple of hours to do
the character work and do all the action scenes
and i will compare a lot of this to falcon and
winter soldier i feel like it has the same kind of
energy that you see from falcon winter soldier the
same type of genres that they play in it never
gets crazy in the way that wandavision or the
loki episodes do it has the most in common just in
general with falcon and winter soldier but i think
the idea was is they were so dead set on doing
black widows a film because scarlett johansson
has been this character for so long and she was
this big a-list avengers character for a long time
either been so few female-led marvel movies so
far at least up to this point they were like nope
this is the only way we're gonna do it we're gonna
do it as a movie even if we have to rush a bunch
of these parts of her story also a lot of issues
that they run into with the character development
during the movie could have been solved by just
doing more with her in the marvel films before
this in phase two and phase three but like i said
that's not kevin feige's fault he actually tried
to do more with her character he tried to do a
black widow film a long time ago but up until
about captain america civil war marvel studios was
still under the purview of proper marvel corporate
with isaac perlmutter you probably heard all the
stories about how he vetoed all their attempts
to make super weird films he wouldn't even
let kevin feige make a black panther film
it was until after captain america's civil war
that disney sort of separated marvel studios and
let them do their own thing that's why it took so
long to get black panther and obviously now why
took so long to get the black widow film whereas
under normal circumstances we really should have
been watching this story unfold right after iron
man 2 came out and we met her for the first time
and just speaking about the way they treat the
character the way they write her during this film
i do feel like they build a lot on the good energy
that the russo set up for her in captain america
winter soldier that's still probably one of my
favorite black widow related films even though
she's more of a supporting character during that
that was really when the black widow character
took off for me inside the mcu but because they
waited so long to release this scarlett johansson
has had 10 years to develop her character so
she's great in the movie as natasha it's kind
of like watching robert downey jr come back from
infinity war in avengers end game as iron man
they become their characters to the point where
you know kind of exactly what you're going to get
before you actually see the movies they're so good
as those characters at this point the other real
big home run that they hit with this project is
florence pugh's casting is yelena belova before
the movie came out scarlett johansson was very
clear that they were going to be passing the torch
during the black widow film passing the mantle so
to speak so it's not a spoiler to say that marvel
does have plans for yelena belova in the mcu as
the new black widow we'll see that play out in
the next couple of years and i feel like she's
probably one of the best parts of this movie
just in terms of characters she's also one of the
funniest parts of the movie too like she did a
really great job with the action scenes with the
drama with the whole sister aspect of it because
they are kind of like sisters inside the black
widow program and with the comedic beats that
they give her character it's a little bit like
the energy you get from black widow in the earlier
avengers films when she's with the other avengers
all the rest of the supporting cast is great in
the movie too david harbour is red guardian even
though i feel like they didn't do enough with his
character he's kind of like the russian version
of captain america his backstory is similar to
his backstory in the comics with a couple changes
to update his story for present day because the
mcu timeline kind of shifts forward from the comic
book timeline he's like a non-hydra russian super
soldier the russian and soviet government had
their own super soldier program separate from
the hydra winter soldier program in siberia and
i'll get into that more during my full breakdown
in easter egg videos most of what you see from
him in the trailers is the kind of energy that you
get from him in the movie they use him mostly for
comedic value in some really big action set pieces
but a lot of those action pieces are also played
a little bit for comedy he's like the dad bod
version of captain america but i feel like he
did work as this sort of surrogate father to
natasha rachel weisz is also a fantastic actress
so she does a good job with what they give her
in the film but there really isn't that much of
her in the film like even she and david harbour
are relatively minor parts of this it's really
mostly about what's going on with yelena belova
with a taskmaster character in the black widow
program in general don't worry i will talk about
taskmaster in a second there are going to be a lot
of conversations happening about taskmaster in the
next couple of weeks just because they cover this
in the trailers i don't consider it a spoiler but
yelena belova and natasha were raised like
sisters in the black widow program red guardian
and rachel weisz melina black widow are sort of
their surrogate father and mother the way they
pitched them in the film the supporting
cast is they were meant to be her family
before her avengers family so there are aspects
of her backstory in the mcu that they've changed
a lot from the comic book backstory but if you've
read a lot of black widow comics and you know her
origin story you will see a lot of familiar easter
eggs and references in his service of telling that
backstory there are a lot of beats that they
follow up on like all the budapest references
in earlier marvel movies the whole thing with
drakop's daughter and loki during the first
avengers film a lot of those types of moments
that they do use the black widow film to pay off
i can't say too much about taskmaster without
getting into spoilers because obviously they
set it up to be this big twist during the film but
all the taskmaster stuff was about what i expected
going into the film after seeing all the trailer
footage so yes taskmaster is wildly different
from comic book taskmaster it's more of a tech
based expression of his powers from the comics
and there's this whole thing with the marketing
where they were trying to hide their identity
so the shocking reveal wasn't quite as shocking
as marvel probably thought it was going to be it
overall i wasn't super happy with taskmaster even
though they did give him all the best action fight
scenes during the film as you would expect them to
give taskmaster at least they were able to do that
pretty decently like black widow does get a lot of
really awesome fight scenes but taskmaster's fight
scenes are next level and obviously some of those
scenes do happen with taskmaster so without giving
away spoilers there is a way marvel can redeem
the taskmaster mantle in future marvel phase 4
projects i hope that they take that opportunity
all is not lost if you're a big taskmaster stan
but of all the things in the movie that i feel
like didn't work as well as they could have
taskmaster was probably the biggest but that
doesn't mean that it was bad by any means it
just means that it could have been much better
taskmaster of all the characters was probably
one of the most underdeveloped villains which is
a common theme of mcu movies and as for the whole
disney plus of it all they keep saying that you
have to see this movie in a theater but just to
compare to one of the newer disney plus series
say like falcon and winter soldier because a lot
of the action the choreography is similar compared
to falcon and winter soldier all the black widow
action scenes the choreography the effects the big
set pieces were in order of magnitude bigger like
they did spend more money on them so yes if you
can you should try to see it on a big screen but
really everything looks better in a movie theater
at that scale even janky potato quality rips of
360p old tv shows would look better in a big movie
theater but you will be sitting through the movie
thinking to yourself a couple times at least
they could have actually done this as a disney
plus series and just breaking into like a six
or eight hour event one thing that will make a
lot of black widow fans happy though is they
use the movie to address some of the biggest
complaints that people had about her character
and her storyline during avengers end game in
avengers infinity war most notably that she never
really got any moments at the end of the film
when they were eulogizing everyone and despite
the movie feeling kind of like an afterthought
from a big marvel phase perspective it does come
together as a really good time it is a solid
story so if you loved black widow before this you
will really enjoy the movie but if you hated her
character before or you didn't care about her
before it's not going to completely turn you
around the movie did exactly what it needed to do
though without getting into big spoilers about the
post-credits scenes the post-credit scenes were
almost exactly what i expected them to be they
do use them to connect the movie which is said in
the past to the future marvel phase 4 stuff after
avengers endgame so make sure you do stay after
the credits wherever you're watching the movie
i talked a lot about marvel phase 4 connections
during my falcon and winter soldier videos in my
other black widow trailer breakdown videos most
of what i talked about during those ended up
being what was in the movie so there weren't any
huge mind-blowing surprises or anything like that
big twist that i wasn't expecting even if they had
released the movie last year when they had planned
to none of that would have changed like they
didn't radically alter any of the post-credits
scenes because they delayed the film and i will
do full videos for the post credit scenes when
the movie comes out in a couple weeks but once you
do have a chance to see the movie let me know in
the comments what you thought of it and please be
careful about posting spoilers because most people
will not have seen the movie when i'm releasing
this video but my full loki episode 4 video will
post next make sure you have alerts enabled for
my channel so you don't miss that marvel also
just added a brand new Wandavision post credit
scene so you can click here to learn why they did
that and what is different about the new post
credit scene and click here for my full loki
episode 3 video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!